[موسيقى]
نقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مسؤوله
الامريكيه ان مديره وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه ويليام التقى الشهر
الماضي في كييف الرئيس
كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات ما الذي يمكن قراءته في زياره بيرز
السريه لكييف وما ملامحه ومرتكزات خطط
اوكرانيا للمرحله المقبله وما مدى واقعيه
حديث كييف عن تحقيق نجاح عسكري من اجل دفع
موسكو للتفاوض
انا اعتقد هناك عده امور تقع في خلفيه
زياره بيرنز الى اوكرانيا للامر الاول
المتعلق بالوقوف على اخر تطورات الهجوم
المضاع البلدي كان المفترض ان يبدا قبل
شهرين وتاخر نتيجه لعدم امداد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه المطلوبه حسب طبعا ما تقول
اوكرانيا الامر الثاني متعلق بمناقشه
تطورات هذا الهجوم خاصه فيما يتعلق بان
هناك حاله بطء واضح جدا هناك تملم الغرب
من هذه المساله الامر الثاني متعلق
بامكانيه معرفه سقف التفاوض الاوكراني
خاصه
هذه المساله بمعنى اخر هل هناك لا يزال
تمسك اوكراني بما طرحه الرئيس لدسك قبل
حوالي العام الماضي فيما يعرف بخطه النقاط
العشر التي يتمسك فيها بالسعاده كافه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه المحتله في خلفيه
زياره ايضا الامر يتعلق بما يبدو تمنون
امريكيا من ارتفاع تكلفه الحرب في
اوكرانيا حتى لم نتكلم على الاقل على 54
مليار دولار تم صرفها حتى هذه اللحظه سواء
فيما يتعلق بشكل معاناه اقتصاديه او دعم
عسكري او دعم استخبارات الامر الاخر ايضا
متعلق على ما يبدو هناك حاجه لحسم هذا
الموضوع قبل بدء الموسم الانتخابي في
امريكا الا الولايات المتحده عندما
معلومات
في البدايه تقوم بنشرها على شركائها
المقربين نحن قريبين في العلاقات مع
الولايات المتحده ولكن بالمقارنه مع كندا
فنحن ابعد بالطبع في العلاقات لذلك قضيه
ان مدير
المخابرات المركزيه بما انه لم يقدم هذه
المعلومات لاوكرانيا هذا يدل على ان مستوى
الثقه قد يكون ليس عاليا
اوكرانيا تقوم بالتنسيق في اعمالها وخططها
ولكن هذا لا يعني اننا بدرجه مئه بالمئه
نقوم
باحاطه شركائنا بخططنا نعم نتحدث اننا
ننوع القيام بخطوات معينه وحسب ما قال
واشنطن بوست اوكرانيا كانت تريد ان تنجح
في الجبهات ثم ان تبدا في المفاوضات ولكن
انا لا اصدق شخصيا ان هناك اي طرف من
الاطراف مستعد للمفاوضات لذلك ليس هناك اي
تربه صالحه للمفاوضات هذا شيء معدوم من
المحتمل بعد النجاحات معينه من قبل
اوكرانيا في الجبهات كما تحدثت الجريده
الامريكيه ان بعد ذلك قد تكون اوكرانيا
قريبه من البدء في المفاوضات في روسيا
الجامعيين مص
رين على الاستمرار في هذه الحرب
واننا علينا ان ننتصر على الجيش الاوكراني
والبعض يعتقد اننا ليس مواقف مصره او
اعمال فيها اصرار ولكن كل الاحزاب يريدون
الاستمرار في العمليه العسكريه وليس هناك
اي انقسام في المجتمع ويعتقد الجميع اننا
كاروسيين يجب ان ننتصر في العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه حتى ندعي النظام
الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
اعتقد نحن وزاء حالا من شك الغربي في قدره
اوكرانيا على القيام بصد الهجوم او بقيام
بهجوم مضاد يحقق كثير من المكاسب على
الارض وبالتالي الذهاب للتفاوض كما جاء
اليوم الخطه التي عرضتها
تقوم على ثلاثه امور الامر المتعلق
باستعاده اكبر قدر من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لم يتم الحديثه عن استعاده كامل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لكن قالوا اكبر قدر الاوكرانيه
خاصه في الشرق والجنوب الامر الثاني متعلق
بامكانيه تحريك منظومه صواريخ ومنظومه
دفاع خاصه في القرب من جزات القرم
وبالتالي دفع روسيا بشكل للتفاوض الامر
للدخول في التفاوض نهايه هذا العام اعتقد
ان هناك شكوك امريكيه خاصه في ظل التقدم
البطيء والتقدم بطيء واسباب جزء منه متعلق
بما قامت به الروسيه بزرع الحقول الغام
كبيره جدا وجود خنادق مفخخه وبالتالي تصعب
من امكانيه زحف وتقدم نقاتل الاوكرانيه
باتجاه الشرق خاصه في مخموت وخريسون الامر
الثاني متعلق بعدم يعني وجود اسلحه تبدو
هجوميه لحد بعيد هناك حاله تحافظ من
اوكرانيا على سبيل المثال مثلا فيما يتعلق
بامريكا هناك تحفظ ورفض تقريبا او ممانعه
في ارسال طائرات مقاتله وكذلك قنابل
نقوديه اما الحديث عن ان الدول الغربيه قد
تتملل هذا كان قد اعلن عنه منذ بدايه
الحرب ولكن اذا عدنا الى عام سابق شهر
مايو من السنه السابقه كان هناك مشكله في
الدول الغربيه انهم لم يكن لديهم ما يكفي
من الاسلحه التي تقدم لاوكرانيا
قدموا لنا رساله واضحه انهم مستعدين
لدعمنا لفترات طويل طويله وهذا يعني انا
اعتقد ان في ضوء هذا الوعد انه لن يقوموا
بالضغط على اوكرانيا لللجوء للمفاوضات